at the core of this is kind of a notion
of ideas
that uh i don't know if you're there's a
lot of people that's
including you eloquently about this
topic but richard dawkins talks about
the notion of memes and let's say
this notion of ideas
you know multiplying selecting in the
minds of humans
do you ever think from about ideas from
the from that perspective
ideas as organisms themselves that are
breeding in the minds of humans
i love the concept of memes i love the
concept of
this horizontal transfer of ideas and
sort of permeating through
through you know our layer
of interconnected neural networks so you
can think of sort of the cognitive
space that has now connected all of
humanity
where we are now one giant
information and idea sharing network
well beyond what was thought to be ever
capable
when the concept of a meme was created
by richard dawkins
so but i want to take that concept just
you know in into another twist which is
the horizontal transfer of
humans with fellowships
and the fact that as people apply to mit
from around the world
there's a selection that happens not
just for
their ideas but also for the cognitive
hardware
that came up with those ideas so we
don't just ship
ideas around anymore they don't evolve
in a vacuum
the ideas themselves influence the
distribution of cognitive systems
i.e humans and brains around the planet
yeah we ship them to different locations
based on their properties that's exactly
right
so so those cognitive systems that think
of
you know physics for example might go to
cern and those that think of
genomics might go to the broad institute
and those that think of computer science
might go to i don't know stanford or cmu
or mit
and you basically have this co-evolution
now of
memes and ideas and the cognitive
conversational systems that love these
ideas and feed on these ideas and
understand these ideas and appreciate
these ideas
now coming together so you basically
have
students coming to boston to study
because that's the place where
these type of cognitive systems thrive
and they're selected based on their
cognitive output and their idea output
but once they get into that place the
boiling and interbreeding of these memes
becomes so much more frequent that what
comes out of it
is so far beyond if ideas were evolving
in a vacuum
of an already established hardware
cognitive interconnection system of the
planet
where now you basically have
the ideas shaping the distribution of
these systems
and then the genetics kick in as well
you basically have now
these people came to be a student kind
of like myself who now stuck around
and are now professors bringing up our
own genetically encoded
and genetically related cognitive
systems
are eight six and three years old who
are now growing up in an environment
surrounded by other cognitive systems of
a similar age
with parents who love these types of
thinking and ideas
and you basically have a whole
interbreeding now of
genetically selected transfer
of cognitive systems where the genes
and the means are co-evolving the same
soup
of ever-improving knowledge and
societal inter-fertilization
cross-virtualization of these ideas
so this beautiful image so these are
shipping these actual
meat cognitive systems to physical
locations they they tend to uh cluster
in uh the biology ones cluster in a
certain building too so like within that
there's
there's uh there's clusters on top of
clusters on top of clusters what about
in the online world is that do you also
see that kind of because people
now form groups on the internet that
they stick together so they
they can sort of uh these cognitive
systems can
uh collect themselves and uh
breed together uh on in in different
layers of
spaces it doesn't just have to be
physical space absolutely absolutely so
basically there's the physical
rearrangement but there's also the
conglomeration
of the same cognitive system it doesn't
need to be
a human doesn't need to belong to only
one community
yeah so yes you might be a member of the
computer science department but you can
also hang out in the biology department
but you might also go online online into
i don't know poetry department uh
readings and so forth or you might be
part of a group that only has 12 people
in the world but that are connected
through their ideas
and are now interbreeding these ideas in
a whole other way
so this um this coevolution of genes and
memes
is not just physically instantiated it's
also sort of rearranged
you know in this cognitive space as well
and uh and sometimes these cognitive
systems hold conferences and they all
get gather around and there's like one
of them is like talking and they're all
like listening and then
they discuss and then they have free
lunch and so on no but
but then that's where you find students
where you know
when i go to a conference i go through
the posters where i'm on a mission
basically my mission is to read and
understand what every poster is about
and for a few of them i'll dive deeply
and understand everything but i make it
a point to just go post after poster in
order
to read all of them and i find some gems
and students that i speak to that
sometimes eventually join my lab
and then sort of you're you're sort of
creating this permeation
of you know the transfer
of ideas of ways of thinking
and very often of moral values of social
structures
of you know just more
imperceptible properties of these
cognitive systems that simply just cling
together
basically you know there's i have the
luxury
at mit of not just choosing smart people
but choosing smart people who
i get along with who are
generous and friendly and creative and
smart and
you know excited and childish
in their in you know uninhibited
behaviors and so forth
so you basically can choose yourself to
surround
you can choose to surround yourself with
people who are not only cognitively
compatible but also you know
imperceptibly through the meta cognitive
systems
compatible and again when i say
compatible not all the same
sometimes you know sometimes all the
time
the teams are made out of complementary
components not just compatible but
very often complementary so in my own
team i have a diversity of
students who come from very different
backgrounds
there's a whole spectrum of biology to
computation of course but within biology
there's a lot of realms within
computation there's a lot of rounds
and what makes us click so well together
is the fact that not only do we have a
common mission a common passion
and a common you know uh view of
the world but that were complementary in
our skills
in our angles with which we accommodate
and so so forth and that's sort of what
makes it click
yeah it's fascinating that the the the
stickiness
of multiple cognitive systems together
includes both the commonality so you
meet because you're
there's some common thing but you stick
together
because you're dif different in all the
useful ways
yeah yeah and my wife and i i mean we
adore each other like
two pieces but we're also extremely
different in many ways and that's
beautiful but i love that about
about us i love the fact that you know
i'm like living out there in the you
know world of ideas and i forget
what day it is and she's like well at 8
am the kids better be to school
and uh you know i i do get yelled at
but but i need it basically i need her
as much as she needs me and she
loves interacting with me and talking i
mean you know last night we were talking
about
this and i showed her the questions and
we were bouncing ideas of each other and
it was just
beautiful like we basically have these
you know
basically cognitive you know
let it all loose kind of dates where you
know we just
bring papers and we're like you know
bouncing ideas etc so
you know we have extremely different
perspectives
but very common you know goals and
interests and anyway
you